Emma prefiere cambiar su nombre y
ocultar su cara a pesar de que desde
junio esta mujer de 29 años vive más
tranquila y abiertamente en Bélgica el
país acaba de despenalizar la
prostitución como consecuencia Emma
puede buscar un apartamento en el que
pueda ejercer legalmente lo que le
evitaría nuevas malas experiencias con
propietarios sin escrúpulos estaba
pagando 1600 euros al mes todo un
efectivo por supuesto ni siquiera había
declarado el contrato por un apartamento
de 40 metros cuadrados Emma puede
ceñirse bajo el estatuto de trabajadora
independiente
podré cotizar para el seguro de
desempleo poder cotizar para la pensión
Bélgica es el primer país europeo en
permitir que cualquiera se registre como
trabajador sexual y el segundo en el
mundo después de Nueva Zelanda en Países
Bajos la prostitución Es legal pero la
ley es mucho más restrictiva objeto
condición de hecho en Países Bajos
tienes que reunir una amplia lista de
condiciones para poder ser considerada
trabajadora sexual por lo que muchas
personas no cumplen estas condiciones
Así que trabajan en la clandestinidad
los opositores a esta legislación alegan
que no protege a las víctimas de
explotación sexual
el proyecto continúa penalizando el
proxenetismo pero el problema es la
definición de este concepto la
definición
para ser considerado proxeneta tienes
que hacer un gran margen de beneficios
sin embargo estas nociones muy vaga y
abierta la interpretación
un argumento que el ministro de Justicia
belga rechaza porque este nuevo régimen
laboral solo aplica quienes sean
autónomas no a dependientes más
vulnerables a la explotación sexual
estamos discutiendo Cuáles deberían ser
las condiciones para que las empresas
contraten a trabajadoras sexuales y ahí
especificaremos que es una relación
laboral normal y Qué es una relación de
abuso
apellido la despenalización de la
prostitución también facilita que
quienes la practican puedan denunciar
agresiones ante la policía es el
comienzo de una nueva etapa para 26.000
personas en Bélgica